two stunning departures in the cable
news universe that are sure to shake up
the landscape welcome to Entertainment
Tonight Michelle Turner is off just a
few months ago they were two of the
highest profile faces for Fox News and
CNN but now both Tucker Carlson and Don
Lemon are out here's the latest so I
want to step back for a moment and take
a quick look at how we got here the
morning began with Don on air but by
lunch he was fired and fired up on
Twitter claiming he found out from his
agent quote I am stunned after 17 years
at CNN I would have thought that someone
in management would have had the decency
to tell me directly I don't believe that
you can't really call a lie a lie a rep
for CNN says Don was quote offered an
opportunity to meet with management but
instead released a statement on Twitter
a source familiar with the situation
says that offer came after his agent
broke the news to Don what happened
there because today we learned he's out
I was not very surprised to see Don
Lemon remove
in fact what prized me was
it was to stay there for
when my CNN canceled last summer I
wondered if Don Lemon was going to be
next he ultimately was moved from prime
time to the mornings but that looked
like a demotion and now this is clearly
a termination the decision also comes
two months after the veteran anchor was
pulled off the air for making this
sexist comment if you Google when is a
woman in her prime it'll say 20s 30s and
40s are you talking about Prime for like
child preparing
then came a blistering expose alleging
Don exhibited a pattern of diva-like
behavior misogyny and troubling
treatment of women dating back nearly
two decades Don denied all those
allegations and our E.T Source says
everyone at CNN is Shook and thought the
controversy had been settled and today
fox news's shake-up has also shocked
staff Fox news media and Tucker Carlson
have mutually agreed to part ways there
was no official reason given why the
network ousted their highest rated and
arguably most controversial hosts one of
my favorite people
Carlson's firing is somehow related to
the Dominion lawsuit that was recently
settled by Fox they fired him because of
messages that were found during the
discovery process I believe there's
material in those private messages that
was incredibly ugly it gave Fox a reason
to remove Carlson ultimately Rupert
Murdoch is the patriarch of fox so
whatever he wants goes the decision
seems to have even blindsided Tucker
during what would have been his final
show on Friday this is how he signed off
and we'll be back on Monday we'll see
you then what's next for Tucker Carlson
do you think I think Tucker Carlson can
write his own ticket
yes and even running for president if he
wants to although he's not going to do
that
[Music]